we've talked about the Trump presidency
as the sword of FoxNews presidency Trump
watches Fox News in the morning Fox and
Friends his first tweets of the day are
often based on what was covered on Fox
and Friends that morning we also know
that Trump shares an advisor with Sean
Hannity in attorney Michael Cohen
whether or not Cohen was ever officially
representing Sean Hannity in a legal
capacity we don't really know but we
know that Cohen and Hannity are in touch
and that Hannity has obtained advice
from Cohen so a lot of connections
between Trump and Fox News and there's
now a new report from New York magazine
which points out that on many nights of
the week Trump and Hannity are having
oddly enough bed time phone calls Trump
is effectively being put to bed by Fox
News propagandist Sean Hannity and
Hannity is reportedly on a list of
cleared friends and family at the White
House switchboard he gets right through
to Donald Trump when he calls and
Trump's routine is increasingly becoming
clear on a day to day basis in the
morning Trump will watch Fox News and
tweet on the basis of what it is he sees
on TV he watches Fox & Friends in the
evenings he talks to Sean Hannity and I
was thinking as I read this very
interesting article in New York magazine
could the contrast be starter to
President Obama who would read as much
as possible he would read fiction and
nonfiction on his own and he would read
just copious political documents in the
mornings and throughout the day and that
there could be no more antithetical
behavior to that of Barack Obama when it
comes to reading than what we're seeing
from Trump and what New York magazine
also points out is that the morning Fox
and Friends routine is not just Trump's
doing clearly Trump likes watching Fox &
Friends
but apparently when Sean Spicer and
Reince Priebus were still press
secretary and chief of staff
respectively they noticed that when
Trump would get up and watch Morning Joe
for example or other channels those had
some less than glowing reports about
Trump and Trump would get so agitated
that it would throw off his entire day
so what freebus and speiser decided in a
sense it's brilliant was get Trump to
watch Fox and Friends in the morning
because it keeps them more calm and
stable because they mostly just talk
about how great Trump is this is like
managing a little kid
it's like he's got the to the two times
a day propaganda file to placate him
he's deliberately been transitioned by
staff off of morning xuxa morning Joe
over to Fox & Friends it's like dealing
with either a kid or a developmentally
delayed adult yeah at the beginning of
his presidency it wasn't great that he
was only watching cable news right
wasn't really reading articles or
getting those presidential daily
briefing
sure but at least he was getting
somewhat of a diversity of opinions like
you had people in the center you had
people on the Left who criticized them
and then you had Fox News sure now it's
just Fox News it's exclusive and the Fox
News diet obviously has its own problems
and current officials are admitting like
here's the problem Fox News sometimes
exaggerates shocking and they also leave
out major stories if it's a story that
at its base isn't a good story for Trump
to be for the trumpets Fox News will
often just not cover it so Trump becomes
fixated because of his Fox News diet on
small insignificant stories that Fox
News focuses on and is completely in the
dark about actual major stories that are
relevant in the grand scheme of things
so it's very very disturbing what's
going on with Crump's media diet but to
get back to the Hannity phone calls for
a second Hannity's role is a little
different than Fox and Friends Hannity's
calls with Trump often leave Trump
feeling like he's just making the right
decision about everything right he's he
Hannity pumps him up to think he's
accomplished amazing things Trump will
come away from these phone calls with
Hannity with new ideas for executive
orders he wants to put through and a
former White House official calls the
Hannity phone calls an effed up feedback
loop that really messes with Trump's
head so the big picture is Hannity and
Fox and friends are running our country
Fox News Corporation President Rupert
Murdoch reportedly also on that list of
people who can get right through at the
White House switchboard to Donald Trump
and there's really just no comparison to
what's happening at the White House and
I was just thinking you know George W
Bush is really benefiting from Donald
Trump being president and the Washington
Post put out an article to that extent
and it is stunning I mean George W Bush
was a terrible president right he made
some of the worst political decisions in
a long time
a stress economy went to war under false
pretenses led to thousands tens of
thousands of civilian and military
deaths and the approval rating
retrospectively for george w bush is way
up because the contrast to donald trump
makes people say hey you know Bush Bush
wasn't really that bad and that's
dangerous number one because I've talked
before about the last thing we want to
do is get fooled into seeing the
disastrous neocon Bush doctrine of the
project for a new American Century as
anything short of horrifying but it's
true that compared to what were say I
mean but Bush at least read books right
it they weren't the books I might have
chosen necessarily but the guy was at
least reading so this is really really
scary stuff and by the way yet another
link between the Trump administration
and Julian Assange remember that Julian
Assange was in touch with Donald Trump
jr. during the campaign who of course is
directly linked to Donald Trump Julian
Assange was also in touch with Sean
Hannity during the campaign which is yet
another way in which it's completely
plausible that the Trump administration
was in touch with Assange and it's
another mutual point of contact for them
just like Michael Cohen is yeah and one
more thing on Hannity I mean when Hannah
he's done when he show's over at ten
o'clock p.m. yep
do you really want to watch Laura
Ingraham or do you want to get the bonus
Hannity and I think that's what Trump is
opting to do yeah where do we know what
Trump thinks about Laura Ingraham I
don't know is that something I don't
think yeah he hasn't taken a position
yeah that show is unwatchable by the way
and hopefully it'll be off the air soon
the video you just watched was made
possible by support from you please go
to patreon.com slash david pakman show
you can make a pledge of as little as
one dollar per month and every dollar
helps to support the work that we're
doing particularly in light of the
YouTube ad boycott which has been really
bad